[Musik]
ein stiller samstag in deutschland um
das virus endlich einzudämmen müssen
viele menschen seit heute zu hause
bleiben 150 milliarden gegen die krise
die bundesregierung plant ein enormes
hilfspaket mit neuen schulden in
dreistelliger milliardenhöhe und
abschied von einer legende
kenny rogers stirbt im alter von 81
jahren nach sechs jahrzehnten auf der
bühne
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend hinein und
danke dass sie auch heute bei uns sind
geben sie uns 20 minuten wir geben ihnen
den überblick über diesen nachrichten
samstag der natürlich ganz im zeichen
des weltweiten kampfes gegen das corona
virus steht für uns in deutschland heißt
dass straßen die deutlich leerer sind
als sonst in mehreren bundesländern
gelten ausgangs beschränkungen um die
ausbreitung des virus zumindest zu
verlangsamen
da wird das öffentliche leben zurück
gefahren in einer art wie es in
friedenszeiten nie zuvor geschehen ist
das ist die eine seite auf der anderen
ist dieses wochenende auch ein test
reichen die regeln werden sie
eingehalten oder kommen schon morgen
noch strengere auflagen für uns alle
wir beginnen heute abend im süden von
deutschland sarah schulen und martin
niesen berichten wenn das glockenspiel
des münchner rathauses erklingt dann ist
der marienplatz an einem normalen
samstag mittag voller menschen
aber normal ist spätestens seit
inkrafttreten der bayernweiten ausgangs
beschränkungen nichts mehr
nur wenige sind noch auf den straßen
unterwegs zum lebensmittel kaufen
[Musik]
das kein schlechtes gefühl aber es ist
irgendwie merkwürdig sehr merkwürdig
sehr sehr ruhig sehr geschwänzt bis fast
ein bisschen ins fenster
das ist ja so ein gleitender prozess
gewesen die man all diese maßnahmen so
dass jetzt das auch nicht sowieso ein
völlig unvorbereitet getroffen hat auch
das gehört zur neuen realität in bayern
verstärkte polizeikontrollen passanten
und autofahrer müssen den beamten
erklären warum sie unterwegs sind die
maßnahmen scheinen zu wirken
es gibt kein großes halligalli mehr
irgendwo auf dem straßen es gibt keine
partys in der öffentlichkeit
es hat ganz wenige verstöße gegeben und
ja die polizei abgestellt die
allermeisten haben es kapiert und halten
sich an die vorschriften und das ist das
entscheidende
auch in baden württemberg gelten ab
sofort strengere vorschriften im
öffentlichen raum
ansammlungen von mehr als drei personen
sind verboten ausnahme notwendige
besorgungen viele menschen in stuttgart
zeigen heute verständnis ist glaube ich
die einzige chance um den griff zu
kriegen
wir müssen einfach jetzt an
zu hause bleibt man muss nötigste machen
irgendwann ist es auch die neuen
bestimmungen gelten in baden württemberg
bis auf weiteres in bayern erstmal für
zwei wochen verlängerung nicht
ausgeschlossen
berlins ausgehviertel vergangenen nacht
fast ausgestorben
seit einer woche gilt das club und
kneipen verboten der hauptstadt die
polizei beobachtete kaum feierwütige
gruppen draußen ähnliches bild in
hamburg hier müssen auch restaurants
seit neuestem schließen treffen von über
sechs personen sind verboten für viele
zeigt die verschärfung wirkung
ich habe das gefühl ist es besser als in
den letzten zwei tagen ja das war ein
warnschuss an denen sich jetzt viele
langsamen dran halten sie halten sich
fern von einander machen das gut die
hamburger berlin verkündete am
nachmittag ab morgen sind auch hier die
restaurants dicht einige hatten bereits
maßnahmen ergriffen wochenmärkte finden
statt heute mit weniger besuchern als
gewöhnlich schlange stehen mit abstand
diese verkäuferin weist auf dem schild
auf ihr asthma ich halte den abstand ja
ich gehe nicht direkt an den kunden ran
ich finde das muss reichen alles auf
null zu stellen finde ich ja fußball in
den parks für einen sonnigen samstag
ebenfalls wenig los in den vergangenen
tagen saßen mancherorts noch jugendliche
in größeren gruppen zusammen vor den
wahrzeichen der stadt fast schon
unheimliche stille statt touristen sind
es einheimische die diesen
ungewöhnlichen moment festhalten wollen
verrückt aber so kennt man berlin nicht
allerdings war es in hamburg und berlin
gleichermaßen kühl offen also ob die
einsicht oder doch eher der eisige wind
für diesen ruhigen tag sorgten
deutschland steht angesichts der krise
vor einem radikalen kurswechsel in der
finanzpolitik um arbeitsplätze zu
sichern und firmen zu stabilisieren
plant die regierung einen
nachtragshaushalt und zwar in höhe von
150 milliarden euro
das heißt mehr als 40 prozent der bisher
geplanten gesamtausgaben noch mal
zusätzlich oben drauf
die grenzen der schuldenbremse würden
dadurch massiv überschritten und das ist
nicht alles was die regierung vorhat
cornelia schiemenz hat die details ob
kleiner buchladen mittelständisches
familienunternehmen oder riesenkonzern
kaum ein unternehmen bleibt von der
korona krise verschont
der finanzminister will nun die
schuldenbremse lockern und einen
nachtragshaushalt über 156 milliarden
euro beantragen
vor allem aber profitieren von wir von
der finanzpolitik der letzten jahre dass
die schulden in deutschland so weit
zurückgegangen sind dass unser
schuldenstand jetzt nur 60 prozent der
wirtschaftsleistung beträgt ist die
voraussetzung dafür dass wir jetzt mit
ganzer kraft handeln können um schneller
und schärfer reagieren zu können soll
außerdem das infektionsschutzgesetz
geändert werden
so soll die versorgung mit arzneimitteln
besteuert werden
medizinisches personal könne auch
zwangsrekrutiert werden und die suche
von kontaktpersonen via handy ortung
möglich sein also hier müssen wir sehr
achtsam sein es kann nicht sein dass
auch in einer krise demokratische rechte
und der föderalismus außer kraft gesetzt
wird da werden wir sehr achtsam sein
aber in dieser konkreten situation ist
dass zeitweise und unter präziser
kontrolle möglich mehr zentralisierung
darum wird es auch morgen gehen
telefonschalte der kanzlerin mit allen
ministerpräsidenten auf der tagesordnung
ein thema ausgangssperren darüber
nochmal reden denn das sind ja zahlen
dann muss man erst mal im moment darüber
nachdenken gigantische summen theo koll
guten abend vor ein paar wochen wäre
über einen bruchteil dieser summe noch
lange und heftig gestritten worden
geht das jetzt alles so durch ich glaube
davon kann man ausgehen und das obwohl
beispielsweise der rettungsschirm ja
fast das doppelte des gesamten
bundeshaushalts beträgt in gewisser
weise geht momentan diese krise erzeugt
ungeahnten konsens und außerdem auch
noch politische kreativität das kabinett
wurde vorverlegt auf montag schon am
mittwoch soll der bundestag abstimmen
und am freitag dann der bundesrat also
das land steht zwar stehen aber die
politik rennt aktuell im turbo
schwieriger als die gigantischen
milliardensummen könnte es übrigens
nächste woche
werden überhaupt genug abgeordnete in
den bundestag zu bekommen damit man
einerseits die nötigen mehrheiten
zusammen hat und andererseits
ausreichende virus sicherheit also ganz
praktische probleme
morgen wollen sich die bundeskanzlerin
und die ministerpräsidenten der länder
zusammen schalten die abstimmung der
länder untereinander liefern bisher
nicht unbedingt reibungslos jetzt soll
es auch ganz schnell für den kampf gegen
epidemien mehr zentralen durchgriff
geben aus berlin
wie kommt denn das bei den ländern an
nun so wie man sich das denken konnte
dieser geplante erweiterte durchgriff
des bundes mittels
infektionsschutzgesetz stößt bei den
bundesländern nicht auf allzu große
gegenliebe aber wenn es überhaupt einen
perfekten politischen moment für solche
veränderungen gibt dann jetzt denn
erstens erscheinen diese maßnahmen
absolut sinnvoll und zweitens wird die
kritik an unterschiedlichen vorgehen
einzelner bundesländer ja immer lauter
und wenn man genau hinschaut dann sind
die neuen bundes zuständigkeiten ja auch
durchaus überschaubar die länder würden
ja auch weiterhin beispielsweise über
ausgangssperren entscheiden können sagt
theo koll live aus berlin theo vielen
dank und dann die zahl der infektion und
die zahl der toten ist auch in
deutschland weiter gestiegen
den aktuellen stand und die entwicklung
zeigt david sauer laut johns hopkins
universität wurden in deutschland bis
heute 18.30 mehr als 21.000 800
infektionen nachgewiesen
75 menschen starben weil nicht beliebig
viel getestet werden kann gibt es eine
hohe dunkelziffer
die zahl der bestätigten fälle hat sich
in deutschland zuletzt etwa alle drei
tage verdoppelt bei dem tempo gäbe es
ohne gegenmaßnahmen in nicht mal drei
wochen mehr als eine million fälle
bundesweit die zahl der patienten würde
die behandlungs kapazität der kliniken
weit übersteigen und die sterblichkeit
zu nehmen
wie wirksam dieser trend durch maßnahmen
wie ausgangs beschränkungen verlangsamt
wird zeigt sich erst mit gut einer woche
verzug so lange dauert es bis die
inkubationszeit vorbei ist und
testergebnisse vorliegen
vier neue todesfälle gibt es in einem
würzburger pflegeheim
damit sind dort insgesamt bereits neun
senioren an den folgen einer corona
infektion gestorben
die quelle der infektion ist noch immer
nicht entdeckt auch die pflegerinnen und
pfleger sind betroffen und jetzt
schlagen patientenschützer alarm und
fordern besseren schutz in pflegeheimen
antoine kurschilgen
nun ist also das passiert was viele
befürchtet haben dass kroner virus
dringt in ein pflegeheim ein mit
dramatischen konsequenzen innerhalb
weniger tage sterben neun bewohner viele
weitere werden infiziert 5 liegen im
krankenhaus zehn komapatienten werden
isoliert auf ihren zimmern behandelt
trotzdem soll das pflegeheim nicht
evakuiert werden
es sieht im moment nicht so aus als ob
wir irgendetwas im alltag jetzt ändern
müssten weil nach dem was wir heute von
würzburg wissen ist in der tat ein
einzelner angehörige pflegende berufe
waren der das virus hinein getragen hat
und eine hundertprozentige garantie
davor dagegen können wir wahrscheinlich
auch nicht schaffen
auch 23 pfleger haben sich angesteckt
sie sind zu hause in quarantäne seit dem
ersten todesfall von gut einer woche
gilt hier ein striktes besuchsverbot
pfleger müssen schutzanzüge und
atemmasken tragen
und trotzdem war das virus nicht
aufzuhalten pflegeheime sind hoch
risikozonen patientenschützer
kritisieren es fehle an
spezialausrüstung wir fordern dass die
bei der verteilung pflegeeinrichtungen
genauso bedacht werden arztpraxen und
krankenhäuser
der augenmerk im moment das solid und
und zwar nicht nur für die pflegeheime
also die stationären einrichtungen
sondern auch für die ambulante pflege
von denen auch ein großes
ansteckungsrisiko osten vergessen wir
nicht hier leben 800.000 menschen und
die werden eben auch fast von 800.000
pflegerinnen und pflegern betreut was in
der pflege schief läuft kann die
intensivstation kaum mehr retten sagen
patientenschützer man gucken wir jetzt
noch mal live nach würzburg zum stefan
schlosser stefan wie geht denn die stadt
jetzt mit dieser situation um
ja das ist eine extrem schwierige
situation für alle beteiligten das virus
ist in der einrichtung jetzt kann es nur
noch darum gehen weitere ansteckungen zu
verhindern
dafür sind alle bewohner isoliert in
ihren zimmern eine evakuierung würde zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt keinen sinn machen
denn erstens wohin mit den menschen hier
werden sie ja immerhin versorgt und
zweitens die bewohner sind hochbetagt
schwer pflegebedürftig und viele von
ihnen auch dement sie jetzt aus ihrer
gewohnten umgebung zu reißen würde die
situation eher noch verschlimmern
nur wer wirklich starke symptome zeigt
zum beispiel atemnot oder im fieber geht
umgehend ins krankenhaus gebracht so
versucht man hier durch noch bessere
schutzmaßnahmen der sache herr zu werden
das bringt natürlich auch das
pflegepersonal an ihre belastungsgrenze
auch psychisch dann schließlich ist das
hier der ort an dem fast die hälfte
aller todesfälle in bayern sich ereignet
haben
umso wichtiger ist es dass solche
einrichtungen weiterhin mit
schutzausrüstung versorgt werden denn
eins ist auch klar so ein fall wie hier
in würzburg der kann auch anderen ort
passieren und dann möglicherweise auch
mit ähnlich dramatischen konsequenzen
stefan vielen dank für diese information
heute abend dringend benötigt werden es
mehrfach schon gehörte in diesen tagen
atemschutzmasken zehn millionen will der
bund nach und nach an die länder abgeben
nachschub in erster linie für
medizinisches personal und für besonders
gefährdete menschen das land brandenburg
hat heute eine lieferung von 50.000
sogenannten ffp zwei masken erhalten und
kann damit eine bedrohliche lücke
zumindest vorübergehend schließen
die masken werden an den
niedergelassenen ärzte im land verteilt
denn ohne sie können keine patienten
behandelt oder getestet werden
fast 800 weitere tote meldet italien so
viele wie noch nie seit ausbruch der
korona pandemie damit sind dort schon
mehr als 4800 menschen gestorben
und auch in den usa breitet sich das
virus gerade immer schneller aus mehr
als 22.000 infizierte zählt die johns
hopkins universität mindestens 278
menschen sind nach kona infektionen
gestorben
das sind rund dreimal so viele wie vor
drei tagen ein epizentrum der epidemie
ist new york city dort wie im gesamten
bundesstaat new york gelten seit gestern
die strengsten ausgangs beschränkungen
der usa
die stadt die niemals schläft soll zur
ruhe kommen johannes hano
es ist ein rennen gegen die zeit überall
auch hier new york city die
weltmetropole gilt mittlerweile als
hochrisiko gebiet sowie johann iran oder
die lombard 6000 infektionen etwa 30
prozent aller fälle in den usa ab und
dabei wurde mit dem testen gerade erst
begonnen die zahlen steigen mit einer
rate um mehr als das doppelte unserer
krankenhaus kapazitäten an das dreifache
unsere intensivstation wetten
wir bekommen keine zusätzlichen
beatmungsgerät ich kann auf dieser seite
der gleichung nichts ändern ich kann
keine neuen intensivstation betten mit
beatmungsgeräten schaffen das einzige
mittel das noch verbleiben würde um eine
katastrophe zu verhindern sei wie
überall das abflachende infektions kurve
schon jetzt wirkt die metropole fast wie
eine geisterstadt
ab sonntag wird new york praktisch ganz
dichtgemacht höchst bürgermeister
fordert den einsatz des militärs zur
medizinischen und logistischen
unterstützung der stadt und er ist
wütend auf die regierung in washington
wir sind das epizentrum und ich habe die
regierung immer wieder gebeten uns
medizinische grundausrüstung zu
beschaffen
aber es gab keine bedeutende reaktion
wenn wir keine hilfe bekommen werden wir
menschen verlieren die nicht sterben
müssen alle geschäfte und hotels
geschlossen die wolkenkratzer verweist
viele krisen und katastrophen hat new
york schon hinter sich und gemeistert
die nächsten wochen aber werden
entscheidend dafür sein ob der mythos
new york weiterlebt afrika ist in großen
teilen ein weißer fleck in der korona
statistik seit heute gibt es offiziell
mehr als 1000 infizierte auf dem ganzen
kontinent 14 staaten melden überhaupt
keine infektionen
ob das so stimmt unklar wo nicht
gemessen wird können auch keine
infektionen dokumentiert werden
die erste infektion in kenia wurde vor
gut einer woche bestätigt und seitdem
greift die regierung durch schließt
schulen universitäten gotteshäuser und
das ist das große risiko in den armen
vierteln der afrikanischen metropolen
leben millionen menschen auf engstem
raum zusammen aus nairobi tim kröger
beten gegen korona heute mittag in
nairobi die kenianische regierung hat
zum nationalen gebetstag aufgerufen
nicht in den kirchen moscheen und
tempeln sondern im fernsehen übertragen
um eine verbreitung des virus zu
vermeiden
im slum jedoch stehen sie dicht gedrängt
vor dem apparat dabei wäre ein größerer
ausbruch gerade hier verheerend die
regierung hilft uns nicht nie sagen sie
sollen immer wieder hände waschen aber
es gibt kaum was meine ich habe angst
weil das virus menschen umbringt also
muss ich meine hände waschen sauberkeit
halten und menschenmassen meiden soziale
distanz aber ist schwierig in den slums
die häuser stehen eng viele menschen
lieben auf wenig raum
außerdem ist die hygienische situation
desolat desinfektionsmittel seife und
wasser sind teuer für die armen menschen
ein großes problem sind die vielen
falschen informationen also sogenannte
fake news die nicht nur hier im slum
sondern in ganz kenia eigentlich ganz
afrika derzeit über das corona die ruß
im umlauf sind
deshalb setzen die hilfsorganisationen
auf aufklärung in linz land ein problem
kann aber auch das schwache
gesundheitssystem werden die
medizinischen einrichtungen wo es
verdachtsfälle gibt weiß das personal
nicht wie es richtig damit umgehen soll
die meisten slumbewohner leben außerdem
von der hand in den mund ein längerer
wirtschaftlicher stillstand während
eines größeren ausbruch wäre für sie
fatal zurück zu uns nach deutschland wo
im kampf gegen korona jetzt geprüft wird
ob und wie man handy daten der menschen
nutzen könnte die neuen chancen wecken
aber auch alte skepsis führt uns corona
am ende auf den weg in den
überwachungsstaat wo liegen
möglichkeiten und wo sind grenzen sven
ricken hat recherchiert
jeder dieser punkte ist ein handy die
bewegung von tausenden geräten ist auf
der karte zu sehen
die software findet jeden treffpunkt
weiß wer wie lange mit wem an
einem ort war die firma jubiläums in
hamburg arbeitet mit solchen
freiwilligen daten je mehr dabei
mitmachen desto mehr wird das helfen und
ich denke auch dass man natürlich
darüber nachdenken kann
wie kann ich auch selber sehr schnell
ein update bekommen bin ich in einem
risikogebiet gewesen
treffpunkte gemeinsame aufenthaltsorte
für virologen unschätzbare vorhersage
daten
die telekom hat bereits 1 5 gigabyte
großes paket an das robert-koch-institut
geliefert anonym ein sehr grobes raster
aufgeschlüsselt nach funkmasten nur
deshalb hat deutschlands oberster
datenschützer zugestimmt
die daten lassen nicht die bewegung
einzelner handy nutzer erkennen sondern
die sind dort in gruppen zusammengefasst
anonymisiert man kann bewegung ströme
sehen sieht wie viele menschen haben zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt von einem ort
zu einem anderen begeben massenhafte
personalisierte handy ortung ist in
deutschland verboten in china haben die
behörden damit große erfolge erzielt
bewegungen ließen sich nachvollziehen
infektionsherde ausmachen für kritiker
aber noch lange kein grund die
ungefragte handy datenanalyse zur regel
zu machen
es gibt das recht auf informationelle
selbstbestimmung und wenn das jetzt
sozusagen unter dem deckmantel der
korona bekämpfung gekippt würde würde
ich das für sehr problematisch halten
also hier müssen wir tatsächlich
aufpassen dass da in den nächsten wochen
wir nicht irgendwie eine situation
gelangen wo wir so demokratische
grundrechte aufgeben jens wille und sein
team arbeiten mit dem medizinischen
hochschule hannover zusammen eine
solchen app auf freiwilliger basis ist
bereits in arbeit jeder kann darin
selber entscheiden welche daten zur
verfügung stehen das hilft dann der
wissenschaft und jedem einzelnen soviel
zunächst zu diesem thema in dieser
sendung aber auch heute gibt es ein zdf
spezial zur corona epidemie direkt nach
uns und jederzeit informiert bleiben sie
mit unserem live blog online auf heute
de und in der heute app gestern die ece
hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke zwischen
köln und frankfurt wird ziel eines
mutmaßlichen anschlagsversuch
heute hat die polizei in dem
zusammenhang einen 51 jährigen deutschen
festgenommen
ein bahnmitarbeiter hatte gestern
bemerkt dass an den gleisen die
schienenbefestigungen gelöst worden
waren
die strecke ist mittlerweile repariert
und wieder freigegeben
warum die gleise offenbar sabotiert
wurden ist noch unklar
sechs jahrzehnte im musikgeschäft mehr
als 120 millionen verkaufte platten drei
grammys kenny rogers ist eine country
legende der mann mit der rauchigen
stimme und dem silbernen barth war vor
allem in den 70er und 80er jahren ein
superstar
einige seiner songs wurden welthits
kenny rogers ist tot er wurde 81 jahre
alt der nachruf von tom pollock
vor
[Musik]
lucille einer von kenny rogers größten
hits 1977 bekam er dafür in den usa
nicht nur einen preis für die country
single des jahres sondern auch den
wichtigsten musikpreis der welt seinen
ersten grammy
viele auszeichnungen folgten
nummer-eins-hits kenny rogers war ein
superstar der seinen eigenen weg suchte
um erfolgreich zu bleiben
ich kann tun was alle anderen auch
machen und versuchen es besser zu machen
das kann ich kaum schaffen
oder ich mache etwas das niemand anderes
macht und wo sich keine vergleiche
aufdrängen
[Musik]
anders als andere einzigartig so wie
sein duett mit dolly parton islands of
the stream der beginn einer langjährigen
freundschaft auch abseits der bühne
das war mein glückstag als ich kenne
traf und für einen sin das team aus
genommen haben und gott wir hatten
danach ganz viel zeit miteinander
kenny rogers war vielseitig probierte
pop jazz er war fotograf doch seine
leidenschaft blieb die country music
auch brisante themen wie rassismus
packte er in seine songs
sie hatten gesellschaftliche bedeutung
sind nicht nur ein bündel von wörtern
die geschickt zusammengefügt sind mehr
als 60 jahre im showbusiness ein sternen
der country music hall of fame erinnert
daran
letzte nacht starb kenny rogers im kreis
seiner familie
er habe sich nie als großartigen sänger
gesehen hat er mal gesagt kenny rogers
war vor allem ein großartiger
geschichtenerzähler
so und jetzt am ende dieser sendung noch
dass hier was kommt dabei heraus wenn
man plötzlich sehr viel zeit hat zu
hause bleiben muss und trotzdem das
arbeiten nicht lassen kann
robbie hunke ist fußball kommentator und
er blickt jetzt vom wohnzimmerfenster
aus ins stadion
sozusagen die klassische nachmittags
anstoßzeit wenig los im moment habe ich
aber ein naturtalent hier erwischt was
macht er jetzt der sco
außerdem ist ein handspiel dabei da
packte einer mitten auf der kreuzung ich
glaube dass der schiedsrichter ihn mit
einer gelben karte davon kommen dass er
geht über die straße und das ist korrekt
denn es ist grün es ist nicht rot und
jetzt ist auch grün für den herrn de die
e roller weg gebracht hat wie gerichts
ab jetzt ist alles korrekt kommt mit
gelb davon und robbie hunke unterhält
damit auf social media in der
fußballlosen zeit
das wetter sehr sonnig aber einige
nächte erwarten uns stand ali hat gleich
mehr dazu das gesamte team der 19 uhr
sagt danke dass sie heute dabei waren
morgen gerne wieder um 23.15 informiert
sie aber erstmal marietta slomka im
heute journal
ein weiterer besonderer nachrichten tag
geht zu ende
machen sie wo immer das geht sich ein
angenehmer
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter dieses
umfangreiche hoch hört auf den namen
jürgen und lenkt mit freundlichen grüßen
aus dem polarkreis kalte luft nach
deutschland und die ist ziemlich kalt
die luft und wird noch etwas kälter in
der nacht denn die wärme die restwärme
strahlt in den weltraum aus es gibt
nämlich kaum wolken im norden im süden
dafür mehr
hier fällt regen und schnee bis auf etwa
600 meter herab generell müssen sie vor
allem im süden mit überfrierender nässe
rechnen
vor allem bei temperaturen bis auf minus
neun grad zum beispiel im vogtland
sinken minus sechs grad eine reise im
süden knapp knapp unter null grad die
frost werte frostfrei im südwesten bei 3
grad
morgen gibt es viel sonnenschein und ein
bögen ostwind der ist ziemlich
ungemütlich ja und die temperaturen
steigen dabei auf 0 grad im vogtland und
12 grad im südwesten deutschlands in den
nächsten tagen gibt es wenig änderungen
sehr viel sonnenschein und temperaturen
zwischen ein und zehn grad im grunde
genommen ändert sich daran wenig ein
schöner abend